[музика]
перш за все всі шукають відповідь що не
так з Росією
чому Кремль не може отримати економічний
розвиток і забезпечити процвітання але
не війну
Чому вони творять цілковите божевілля
У мене є відповідь
Росія все ще Імперія
середньовічний діапазон імперія
Імперія з фантомним болем за поразку в
холодній війні
це не цікавить процвітання Це як у
Радянському Союзі не мати штанів але
здаватися дуже великим зараз те саме
Я не знаю що якась Імперія припинила
завойовницькі війни своєю доброю волею
можливо за винятком Великої Британії
після Другої світової війни
Росія гине Імперія намагаючись вижити
завойовуючи свої колишні території але
єдине що вона досягне це відцентрований
процес
нам Також потрібно обговорити що робити
з майбутніми частинами імперії та Другий
шанс для нуклеаризації який ми не
повинні втрачати як у 1991 році але
зараз критично важливо Не залишити
Москві жодного шансу вчепитися за
Рятувальний Круг
Росія стоїть перед шекспірівським
питанням
Бути чи не бути
це означає поставити під загрозу світову
систему безпеки
24 лютого стало точкою не повернення не
тільки для нас і для Москви а й для
всього світу
успіх Росії в Україні означає не лише
триваючу агресію проти колишніх
радянських республік включаючи нинішніх
балтійських членів НАТО
це супроводжується ворожують діяльністю
так званого поясу зла Ірану Північної
Кореї Китай ймовірно спробує взяти під
контроль Тайвань ігноруючи закон про
відносини з тайванним якщо Пекін
зрозуміє що Сполучені Штати Америки не
надто рішучі щоб зберегти цей акт
не бути для Росії це шанс знищити
імперію яка не перестає жити в
середньовіччі це сигнал світу що Погані
хлопці все ще програють а світову
безпеку потрібно серйозно змінити але
зберегти